One physical phenomenon that is sometimes factored into the illumination model
is described by the Fresnel equations. These equations were discovered by the
French engineer and physicist Augustin-Jean Fresnel. He received little
recognition of his work in optics while he was alive. Much of it was published
after his death in 1827. Happily, what evidently gave him the most pleasure was
the discovery and experimental confirmation of his scientific theory. The
Fresnel equations themselves have to do with the amount of reflection and
refraction off a surface. The basic relationship is this, the more on edge you
look on a surface, the reflective it is. If the surface is refractive, in other
words transparent, the amount of light transmitted will drop off considerably
as you approach the shallow angle. My favorite example is a lake or the ocean.
The next time you're in shallow water, notice that you can look straight down
and see the bottom. As you look out towards the horizon, the angle of your eye
to the surface's normal approaches 90 degrees and reflection will dominate. For
materials that aren't transparent, this effect still takes place. The Fresnel
effect is particularly noticeable for what are called dielectrics, which is a
fancy way of saying insulators. In other words, material such as glass,
plastic, and clay. For example, glass is about 25 times as reflective at a
shallow angle than directly head-on. An experiment you can do right now to
prove this to yourself. Take a sheet of normal paper, nothing very shiny or
rough, and put it on a flat surface such as a book. Hold the paper so that
you're hold it nearly edge on and look towards a lit area, such as a window.
Here I'm using the tablet. At nearly 90 degrees to the surface, normally you
will see the paper become quite reflective. In fact, the Fresnel effect should
also lessen the diffuse contribution. As the object becomes more reflective in
real life, there are less photons left to go off in other directions. There is
one implementation detail I want to mention. You should use the normal that
represents the mirror orientation. For example, for a mirror reflective
surface, this is simply the shading normal. For most other materials, it's not.
With the Blinn-Phong illumination equation, the idea is that the material is
made of microfacets. Only a few facets are angled just right to reflect light
towards the eye. These facets have normal vectors pointing exactly halfway
between the light and eye vectors. Recall that the special direction is called
the half-angle vector. Happily, this is a vector we compute anyway for specular
highlighting, but it's important to use this direction and not the shading
normal. Try the demo to get a sense of the effect. Notice how a nearly edge on
angle causes the reflectivity to increase.